en este vídeo vamos a recordar un tema
que es la covarianza
covarianza entre dos variables
aleatorias
entre dos variables
y vamos a desarrollar un poco la
definición de esta covarianza cobrarían
si me falta una en agregarla
y vamos a desarrollar como les decía
esta fue la definición de ccoo varianza
para llegar a una conclusión muy
interesante que se va a relacionar con
otro tema de estadística
para eso supongamos que tenemos la
covarianza entre la variable x y la
variable i y esto va a ser igual al
valor esperado
/
x y su valor esperado
para la redundancia por y menos el valor
esperado de iu
este entonces es la covarianza o la
distancia fíjense que esto es la
distancia que hay de equis o en este
caso de iu a su valor esperado por lo
tanto esta es la definición de
covarianza entre dos variables
aleatorias supongamos que tenemos por
ejemplo que qué pasa si por ejemplo x es
igual a 1 y su valor esperado
está por debajo de nuestra muestra es
igual a cero y tenemos también que y es
igual a 3 mientras que su valor esperado
está por encima de la muestra tres que
es 4 que sucedería en este caso
justamente es un caso muy particular en
dónde
un dato de la muestra está por encima
del valor esperado mientras que otro
dato de la otra muestra está por debajo
del valor esperado bueno en este caso la
covarianza entre x e iu sería igual a 1
por menos 1 que es la distancia que hay
entre un dato y el otro y esto nos daría
igual a menos 1 es decir que si
obtenemos un valor negativo de esto como
éste no significa está significando que
un dato de la muestra está mientras un
dato baja por así decirlo está por
encima de lo que sería el valor esperado
el otro está por debajo del valor
esperado si los dos estuviesen por
encima del valor esperado no
obtendríamos un número negativo y lo
mismo si los dos estuviesen por debajo
tendríamos un número positivo también
pero dejemos a un lado esto por un
momento y vamos a desarrollar
como era la idea principal del vídeo
está fórmula o esta definición de la
covarianza vamos a desarrollar esta
propiedad distributiva que tenemos acá
esta doble distributiva
creemos en esta parte y nos va a quedar
lo siguiente
bueno claro que la covarianza es igual
al valor esperado
de que ocurra
x x y menos x por el valor esperado de i
- y por el valor esperado de x más el
valor esperado de x por el valor
esperado de i
hasta que estamos de acuerdo ahora
podemos distribuir o si lo podemos si me
permiten llamarlo de esa forma
distribuir lo que sería esta el valor
esperado de valores esperados valga la
redundancia esto nos quedaría de la
siguiente manera esto sería el valor
esperado
de xy menos el valor esperado de x por
el valor esperado de iu
- el valor esperado de iu por el valor
esperado de x
más el valor esperado del valor esperado
de x por el valor esperado
de él
que bastante apretado ahí pero bueno una
vez que tenemos esto antes cabe la
aclaración recordemos qué es lo que
sucede si tenemos el valor esperado del
valor esperado de alguna variable esto
es igual al valor esperado de esa
variable y esto tiene lógica supongamos
que el valor esperado de x es igual a 1
y si nosotros tenemos el valor esperado
para ese valor esperado para 1 es lógico
que esto
va a ser uno si tenemos el valor
esperado de uno es el valor esperado de
x que es igual a 1 pero bueno no no
quiero generar un trabalenguas sino
simplemente
recordarles esto que tenemos acá el
valor esperado de un valor esperado es
justamente ese valor esperado y esto nos
va a servir no lo voy a borrar lo voy a
dejar esto nos va a servir para poder
seguir trabajando el este término que
daría igual es el valor esperado de x
- ya casi podríamos hacer como una
especie de factor común por así decirlo
exprese a extraer esto que viene dado
por esta definición nos quedaría
entonces menos el valor esperado de y
por el valor esperado de x lo mismo
podríamos hacer acá con el valor
esperado de x nos quedaría menos el
valor esperado de x por el valor
esperado de iu y finalmente acá
tendríamos estos dos que sería igual el
valor esperado de x x
el valor esperado de iu
si seguimos aplicando métodos
algebraicos podríamos ver
que esto se anularía con esto
por lo tanto
la covarianza
entre dos variables aleatorias xy es
igual al valor esperado
de xy menos el valor esperado de y por
el valor esperado de x
y aquí quiero llegar con todo esto
estos valores nosotros no los conocemos
ni este ni este ni este sin embargo
podríamos aproximar los o estimar los de
la siguiente manera
aquí
el valor esperado de x y se puede
aproximar a la media de x ohrid o de xy
mientras que el valor esperado de y se
puede aproximar al valor medio de iu y
lo mismo para el valor
esperado de x se puede aproximar a la
media de x es decir se puede aproximar
cada uno de estos valores lo que si
aproximamos todo esto obtendríamos que
la covarianza vamos a escribir lo que
abajo nuevamente la covarianza entre dos
variables aleatorias es igual a la media
de xy
menos la media de y por la media de
equis y si hacen memoria esta expresión
vamos a encuadrar la con azul esta
expresión les va a hacer recordar
bueno no justamente esta sino ésta en
particular este miembro les va a ser
recordar alguna otra expresión
si no lo saben o si no recuerdan o los
invito a ver los otros vídeos esto es el
numerador
número bueno numerador
de la pendiente
de la pendiente de la recta
de regresión
recordemos que en la recta de regresión
teníamos que era igual mx más b la m
la m la calculábamos como la media entre
xy menos la media de ahí por la media de
x sobre la media de x cuadrado menos
la media de x al cuadrado entonces esta
expresión de acá esté numerador es igual
a esto de acá y esto es lo que nos
permite ver que los temas
no sé si en matemática o en general y en
estadística no es la excepción se
conectan entre sí
este es entonces la covarianza entre las
variables aleatorias x
y de la misma forma podríamos deducir
que es esta otra expresión el
denominador que es lo que nos falta esto
si prestan atención es igual a x por x
menos
x barra por equis barra y esto
justamente sería
vamos a usar este color esto justamente
sería la covarianza entre dos variables
sobre otras iguales es decir la variable
aleatoria de x y la variable aleatoria x
que no es más ni menos que la varianza
de la variable aleatoria x por lo tanto
la pendiente un software juntado la
pendiente
de la recta de regresión
de regresión
se la puede escribir o se la puede ver
también por esta otro camino que es la
covarianza entre las variables
aleatorias xy sobre la varianza
de equis y de esta forma podemos ver
entonces nuevamente insisto como todos
los temas de matemática están
interrelacionados entre sí y en
estadística nos ocurre esa excepción